KORG
Kids, get the popcorn out.
Let me tell you the story
of the space viking, Thor Odinson.
He was no ordinary man.
He was a god.
KIDS
Whoa!
KORG
After saving planet Earth for
the 500th time,
Thor set off on a new journey.
He got in shape.
He went from
dad bod to god bod.
And after all that...
THOR
Mjölnir!
KORG
He reclaimed his title...
...as the one and only Thor.
Oh, spoke too soon.
THOR
Jane?!
♪♪
THOR
The old ex-girlfriend.
JANE FOSTER
What's it been, like three, four years?
THOR
Eight years, seven months,
and six days, give or take.
VALKYRIE
Am I, uh, sensing feelings?
THOR
Pfft. Ha! Yeah, right.
GORR
The only ones who gods care about
is themselves.
So this is my vow.
All gods will die.
♪♪
THOR
I just want to say that was very,
very impressive
what you did back there.
JANE FOSTER
It was just my first bad guy.
THOR
Ah, you never forget your first.
GORR
You are not like
the other gods I've killed.
[Screaming]
THOR
Because I have something
worth fighting for.
♪♪
ZEUS
Let's see who you are.
I take off your disguise.
And flick!
[Crowd gasps]
KORG
Ooh!
THOR
You flicked too hard, dammit!
JANE FOSTER
Should we help him?
VALKYRIE
I mean, eventually. Grape?
♪♪